je m'appelle pas dit et je suis un petit
robot compagnon buddy est un robot
émotionnel doté d'une intelligence
artificielle
il était au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines jeudi 8 et
vendredi 9 avril
les vaccinés ont pu échanger avec lui
une occasion de découvrir ces nouvelles
technologies
j'ai pour vocation de le tenir compagnie
aux gens chez eux
je peux je peux de recréer du lien
social par exemple je peux aider aussi à
l'apprentissage des enfants je peux les
divertir aussi de leur donner la météo
au vélodrome de 10 pose des questions et
rassure certains sont dubitatifs
d'autres curieux ici c'est une personne
qui le pilote et qui parle mais but 10
est utilisé dans d'autres cadres et à
une voix de synthèse
on a deux cas aujourd'hui qui sont
utilisés le premier cas c'est pour les
personnes âgées le deuxième cas c'est
pour les enfants malades où on commence
à déployer dans certaines écoles body ou
jeudi et sur la chaise de la classe à la
place où l'enfant doit se trouver et
l'enfant pilote buddy ya donc une
application qu'on appelle la
téléprésence la présence de ce robot à
saint quentin en yvelines n'est pas un
hasard
l'agglomération se veut à la pointe de
l'innovation dans le domaine du
numérique le monde accélère il faut que
des structures comme une autre soit en
tout cas à la pointe
de toujours essayer d'inventer et
d'innover et bien sûr la robotisation
est un secteur du numérique qui va
exploser demain il faut qu'on soit aussi
à lies coûte et d'entraîner aussi
d'accompagner mes entendu tous les tous
les projets et ses robots est
entièrement conçu et fabriqué en france